special analysis by sky's data team has
found that four in five areas across
england now have fewer gps compared to
five years ago more than a third of
places have lost more than 10 percent of
their workforce
northern parts of the country have been
particularly hard hit with blackburn
with darwin seeing its numbers full from
45 gps per 100 000 patients to 33 a 27
drop
face-to-face appointments are still
below pre-pandemic levels across england
in the same area just 35.9 percent of
appointments were face-to-face this
summer compared with 87.8 percent in
2019.
skies insane rasheed reports now from
blackburn with darwin where gps and
their patients are calling for more
funding
access to a gp is the first line of much
needed care for julie
two years ago she developed sepsis today
she struggles to see a doctor face to
face
that should be your first point to call
your gp and you should be able to see a
gp no matter what you should always be
able to see a gp
not over telephone
not by video you should be able to have
a gp's appointment within at least 24
hours
it doesn't help that she lives in the
area which was losing gps even before
the pandemic now the frustrations are
too much well you just feel so low you
just sometimes i just feel like crying
out for help and there's just nobody
there it's just gone to dogs basically
that's that's the way the health service
has just gone for the dogs
after years of cuts to budgets and a
waning number of colleagues gps across
the country are in crisis
tell me about the ultrasound scan now
dr murthy has been doing this job for
more than 30 years he loves it but he
says being a gp in blackburn right now
is the most difficult it's ever been
i'm working at the moment almost 10
hours a day
including and i'm also working on the
weekends just to catch up some urgent
work not the routine work
and that is the reality of it we are
seeing 40 50 patients either on
telephone face to face
and that is per day and by the time in
the evening you are exhausted
it's a situation public health leaders
here say is all too familiar
we lost a year's male life expectancy
during the cobra pandemic we're never
going to recover
equal life chances for our children if
we don't
make sure that everyone has equal and
fair access to gps for the people of
blackburn and darwin health inequalities
isn't a policy on a to-do list it's an
everyday lived experience accessing
primary care is a first port of call but
here and like many other places they're
just not getting through
this is a national problem
one the pandemic exacerbated but it's
gps in the most deprived towns and
cities that face the toughest
consequences
without them our nhs would crack and
crumble
it's clear they need help now more than
ever so they can help those who need it
intermittent rasheed sky news blackburn